.
a finalement été payante.
Après avoir connu des années
difficiles en raison de
blessures, la skieuse de 26 ans
a grimpé su u u u u u u u u u u,
lors du slalom géant
de Kranjska Gora en Slovénie.
VALÉRIE GRENIER, médaillée d'or,
slalom géant de Kranjska Gora
- T'sais, je me suis toujours
dit que je voulaêêêêêêêêêêêêêêêt
justement un podium ou peut-être
du monde. Donc, dans ma tête,
j'allais jamais lâché, puis...
aujourd'hui, c'est fou!
parfaites, elle a devancé
l'Italienne etmimimière au
classement général du slalom,
Marta Bassino, ainsi que
- Surprenamment, j'ai vraiment
pas été stressée entre les deux
descentes, je me sentais super
bien. J'étais très calme,
coéquipières dans le lounge
enenenendant. Puis... c'est ça.
Même au départ, j'étais super
calme, comme umais vraiment rie.
- (speaker): Valérie Grenier
- La skieuse signe donc
du monde à son 90e départ et
est maintenant 7e au classement
général de la discipline.
fracture à la jambe droite en
2019 et traversé une guérisonFre
a dû combattre les doutes,
qui la ralentissaient
sur les pistes.
de voir que j'ai réussi vraiment
à revenir d'une blessure comme
ça. Ça été vraiment difficile
puis
mon retour sur la neige.
- (speaker): Valérie G
- Avec cette belle victoire,
Valérie Grenier devient
depuis 1974 à gagner un slalom
en Coupe d
Mais surtout, elle prouve
qu'elle fait partie
Ici Josie-Alololololon,
Radio-Canada, Montréa